are you guys ready yeah what moated up
on the island there's a zombie mode they
look like zombies yeah they get a zombie
skin on their zombie bodies alright
everybody are you guys prepared to kill
all these people [ __ ] terrifying
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
three two one go to milta
okay well I got about it's southwest of
us it's the city on the shore to the
southwest of us yeah go to green oh [ __ ]
wait what you jumped out and kicked me
out is that a thing Oh did it do that
yeah maybe maybe we hit the default jump
point I don't know there are three
zombies below us that's good okay I'm
going to big blue roof over there is
anyone by me okay I pieced out wait wait
wait
would people abandon their team oh this
is an open thing Oh God we're we're not
good can you can you up me if I get down
yeah we can still revive each other I'm
gonna try to come to you guys I'm
crossing open ground here oh boy this is
Gary are they faster than us no same
movement speed okay cool let me know if
you see anybody coming my there were
some here wait so they just have to
randomly search for us yeah well so the
circles still a thing right so the
circle will push us all together
oh god this is a waiting to get wounded
up before the circle starts to get us
totally [ __ ] that's not a good circle
for you are they
oh is it I'm coming that way
this building is pretty looted mark the
one that I'm being currently yeah I'm
just scouting around trying to keep an
eye out for anymore my buildings
perfectly clear there's nothing hostile
that way keep watch on ministry mark on
the street the South the South okay
I'm a drama either by the little by the
little stairs guard tower okay we're on
the street near you
it was your Zambo they're running away
to the southeast oh I see one find that
behind those boxes over to the right
there you've been avenged thank you
oh I killed awakened got it I'm gonna go
in this building here okay so try really
hard to close doors behind yourself
because then they at least have to break
down the door to get tea right that
means smart I have a care if we need it
we probably will okay I think that it's
a rainy map is not so Moody yeah I
always pick rain for zombies that's not
a that's my doing not the game but it
makes it so much spookier because then
the zombies just [ __ ] come out of
nowhere that's really hope the zombies
can drive cars that would be awesome my
god that's conspicuous well it's I know
I know
alright I'm coming out so there when we
play with less people or with less Ami's
are with more humans we play pistols and
shotguns only that [ __ ] okay because
then it's exhibit well as pistols
shotguns and crossbows cos it's Walking
Dead those zombies
ooh dude what is x-files what's looking
good doesn't really have I think you
were right though dude Allah diddly
diddly doo doo doo doo doo wait this
doors are right in here potty like crazy
I'm gay I got a bad feeling about that
that place zombies can't open doors
that's where I die
oh that's where you die destroy it oh no
that's who's in the building Jack was in
I'm stupid I have room with sunglasses
why you [ __ ] about me there's a little
too vest in there mark if you want one I
could use honest I need some of this
five five six do you want some of them
no no you take it you're good yeah the
guy only have a level one yeah me too I
have an extra four oh no I don't I have
double 4x scopes by the way yeah so
should we should get lots of attachments
lots of guns I sort of stacked the odds
in our favor this time you guys want to
move into milta a little bit and yeah
my first aid ok you guys well we also
have to keep the circle in line the [ __ ]
okay where is it oh my god yeah we have
time to like get into these houses right
on the edge of milta here and do a
little bit of looting and then get the
[ __ ] to the car and get out of here I
think should be the plan okay
are you going I'm gonna get an eye on
the outside first I'm a look around how
did you die so quickly we haven't even
seen he died - the only zombie that any
of us have seen good job when I was 3
though I did not
here add or breakdown I just all of a
sudden was it half health getting
punched from behind Wow watch my
perspective I died very heroically very
bravely
that doesn't sound you scream like a
little [ __ ] on our screens yeah and
briefly you know really and bravely and
the scream is just discord static it
sounded very it was oh no not at all you
bested me feed Trudeau I mean wait I
love you but that does not sound like
you yeah I would believe it more if you
just fessed up to the screaming and
called it good we're still gonna be your
friend we're just gonna judge you real
hard okay yeah I did I did I I stood in
the corner shooting my shotgun to the
ceiling throughout throwing my mouse and
screaming let's get let's get back to
the car all right getting back where's
the car at Jack's right it's right on me
okay
anyway time to run for our lives like
baby girls oh you guys have plenty of
time it's a slow circle it is a slow
circle hello friends go on the white
line yeah because we don't have to worry
about gunshots right so you can travel
on the roads and whatever just sort of
that's very true
go north west and drive so we don't flip
over is the most important thing you're
like a baby driving best movie of the
year bro
I've seen so many planes in the distance
ever there should be like better vehicle
to planes a minute never marry much yeah
I mean better
but we're fine we should definitely get
drops zombies will probably camp them
but it's it's worth it because I want an
m249 to mow down zombies with ya cuz
that would be fun not seeing many
zombo's they must have I bet like the
majority of them dropped on pachinko I
know I said that I was like anywhere but
the [ __ ] is probably because you know
that everyone was like I'm just gonna
kill him with the rainy map there could
be zombies laying all around us prone
right now and we would have no fun you
could literally walk up to them while
they're prone and because of their color
scheme with this map they're like the
same color as the dirt no it's
ridiculous and kind of terrifying
they'll just like spring up out of
bushes and [ __ ] out of nowhere it's a
it's it's it's it's it's scary yeah you
guys might need to get in some big
engagements just to clear them out soon
or else they just want to try and like
clear out the school and see if they're
camping over there can you see like like
a leaderboard waved is that a drop plane
not yet how many are left tell you that
weight is dead and so is awakened I
accidentally run someone over in this
field that would be sick I'm just gonna
watch north I hear them I hear them
under the bridge yeah they're swimming
on the north side of the bridge to
trying to get to the other shore so we
might get a drop cool ooh boy there's
someone like at the end of this road he
went up into the forest okay let's see
where that drop goes and play off that
because that is both good for us and
that will attract zombies into it so
hopefully we can clear some up there
to get some military vests well they
just zombies like to camp those because
they know that's where we oh yeah I see
a lot of zombo's running in from the
fields should we wait and fight or
should we should we go
I got you fam I don't even see the drop
[Music]
it's perfect for drifting it drifts more
Tokyo drifts bro it's like cool is this
where we're holding up I'm gonna get up
on this I see one two fifty five
Northwest
okay I see it across the bridge over
there there on the road let's see if I
can pop one I got a I got four X scopes
if you guys want them I got a four X on
my rifle I'm good okay oh you see them
they're crossing the bridge I'll watch
it close one at that Rock 248 tag them
Danger Close to because they can come
from everywhere yeah I'm watching the
eastern side we have a river between us
and them so it does drop it's almost
here about a hundred meters up where oh
my god he snuck up like me do you need
medic no you're good I'm good I'm good
Wow okay you look yeah they're really
easy to dodge you should never take
there are like three of them behind that
rock at 240 right now I got a grenade
yo yeah yeah frag them through wait oh
wait I don't have a frag there's more
crawling up they're trying to assemble
on that rock I don't have a I don't have
the means by which to oh wait yes I do
have oh I do have a frag let me try to
so many on that rock frag them fraggin 4
to 5 let's try and push them off the
rock yeah don't let them flee finish
them up one on the rock oh yeah they can
revive each other
if you leave if you leave zombies down
but not dead they can be revived
oh oh my god there they are
I'm down I think being in the middle of
an open field was scary in bed did you
gain crash though we can always bail oh
no I got a first date I'm going to get
rejoin custom games you can rejoin okay
problem yeah you do those I think that
was the most of them in this area god
they sneak up on your quick anything
yeah yeah I don't feel so bad for dying
the rain gives them pretty effective
cover yeah my god where are you guys oh
no oh I see you I see oh circle is
closing
yeah was the first test of your
friendship survival yeah we've been
friends for like three years yeah that
was the first test
oh [ __ ] yeah there you go
oh you got hurt by the car right no it's
fine it's just a little bit of a scooch
I can't shoot on a bike that's stupid no
I can see all the names of people [ __ ]
right now it's scary-looking oh where
where there's 70 70 guys behind you to
your right just like 12 of them very
close oh yeah Danger Close oh geez
that's like a leaping jumping punch okay
we scored the bridge so we actually have
clear view on them yeah that'd be nice
you should heal up as soon as you can
boy yeah the plane was like [ __ ] this
I'm out oh man I'm gonna run out of ammo
go like north into this area
mark okay which guy there's a guy down
right over where you were looking to
your left over the rocks there Oh what
what to your left Jack left left oh this
guy left left God so there's one on the
bridge well coming up from behind
kind of Street there you go guys
green ah sure
I hope you guys find long wait this guy
right there right there right there
behind it or to the right he's wrong
he's one of my one of my patreon people
I think I have so much Wow kill them
with a headshot Jesus I don't like the
way they begged for mercy before you
kill when I saw like zombies mode for
this game I think there's no way that
the zombies can kill you you can just
get so much ammo and kill them you know
have a backpack and you have to carry
all your sit around and sake terrified
it's like the most realistic sense of a
magazine in a game yet like oh my god
the car oh no I see them it's like
everywhere I look there's another guy
running oh I heard that oh my god and
you just drove it's like a lot of them
behind you that's just like I heard the
car it's literally like a zombie horde
they hear you
[Music]
Jack that's what you want oh my god
don't worry the circle is only about to
be tiny alright there's so many in the
circle right now shut up Bob
oh I can see where drops are that's
interesting now that I'm in like God
spectator mode I can see where air drops
are on the map and there's like an
energy drink or whatever and use those
boosts I got an 8x scope yeah that's
what I need right now Jesus Christ
because they are so far away yeah
interesting fun fact the best melee
weapon is actually the frying pan does
it does 20 more damage per hit than the
rest of the melee weapon I hear someone
the circles not with us oh my god you
guys are [ __ ] by the circle the Horde
was coming after you and then the circle
chains and they were like [ __ ] this
guard the edge of the circle
[Laughter]
he's like Team spectating you look
normal but I can see everything since
I'm not like a partner I have like a I
can free spectate I can spectate any
player in the game
[Laughter]
don't go in that building guys for God's
like 20 of them in that one building
oh no no time okay running you got so
many on you jack
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]